the Duke of Sussex was back in the UK
soon to step away from royal duties and
it seems keen to drop the airs and
graces he's made it clear that we are
all just to call him Harry
so ladies and gentlemen please give a
big warm Scottish welcome to Harry the
event was for travela stand initiative
he hopes will make tourism more
environmentally friendly we believe the
travel is a good thing it is the heart
of human experience of cultural
connections and of new friendships that
passion for travel has taken on a new
meaning since we found out the Sussex
ears are going to split their lives
between the UK and Canada how they're
going to make that more environmentally
friendly is already under scrutiny but
Aisha hazarika who was comparing the
event believes that even with the
criticism Harry still has widespread
support people of my age and younger
we've been look up to them as two people
who really stood up to the bullies and
said no we're not having it we're going
our own way we're doing it our way and I
think a lot of people will give them a
lot of respect for that and I think
they're gonna be big names for a long
time to come with or without their fancy
royal title it was fairly obvious that
Prince Harry was never going to talk
publicly about what's been going on
behind the scenes
he has always been frustrated that
there's been too much focus on his
private life rather than the causes that
matter to him but Harry and Megan have
been making it very clear in other ways
that they are not entirely happy about
how things are panning out when it comes
to their new life last weekend on their
sussex royal website they suggested they
are being treated differently from other
members of the family who are
financially independent and appeared
unhappy about having to drop the word
royal from their brand saying the
monarchy didn't have any control over
the word internationally seen as
disrespectful towards the Queen by some
and a sign of the influence of the
American PR agency sunshine Sachs
who've been advising the couple so
Brittany you are protecting the Queen
and talking about
things are in britain but if you're
sitting in north america as they are now
and they have north american advisors
things are done right differently in
north america so i think you now have a
clash of cultures harry and megan will
carry out their final engagements as
working royals over the next few weeks
wanting us to focus on the causes that
matter to them but the contradictions
between what the palace says and what
the Sussex is seem to want is still
proving to be too much of a distraction
Rhiannon Mills Sky News in Edinburgh